انا بشكر انه يوم الانطلاقه بثلاثه ثلاثه
كان يوم ربيعي ومشمس وجميل
بس كان العالم عم يغلي حتى كانه الكره
الارضيه موضوعه على صفيح ساخن
هلا كان كل شيء جاهز لننطلق بالنشره
الاولى اللي هي كانت الساعه عشره بتوقيت
جرينتش يعني الساعه الواحده بعيده الظهر
في توقيت مكه المكرمه وكان الي شرف انه
انا اطلق النشره الاولى في قناه العربيه
وهذه لحظه انا ما بنساها تحضيرات كانت
ضخمه
تحديات كبيره يعني لوجستيه فنيا تقنيا
لانه اخذنا مرحله كبيره من
تحضيرات ولكن كان في فكره واحده عم بتهيمن
على ذهن الجميع انه العالم بحاجه الى
العربيه ففي ذلك التاريخ ولدت العربي
الفرنسيه عن وزير
[موسيقى]
من بغداد
شيئا فشيئا ولكن بسرعه حولت العربيه
الاعلام العربيه الى الابد المعادله بسيطه
المعلومه قبل كل شيء
كان لابد ان تغير نبض الصباح وهكذا تجرات
العربيه ذات صباح وولد صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]